[Music]
you're gonna get through holiday back on
the floor as well as JJ Revit holiday is
about to come back now pardon it the
debt got the whistle so everything is
going to go to James Horton
marco goethe rich also out there for the
grizzlies has his Kyle Anderson aka
slow-mo hardy started
all baked in the durian that that one
was pure there's hardness transition
[Applause]
step back three this gun that's 13 in
the first seven and a half minutes for
James Harden's snapback a hardened guy
look at Harding and there's some contact
down low this could have been an an one
but just amazing the beer look at the
footwork on the quick step back nobody
does it better in the NBA harden cata
and the foul chance for a four-point
play well you have to close this
footwork is just so darn good getting
closer to the basket step back
[Music]
and he steps back hits anyway double
that he sees the double-team coming so
he says I'm just going to step back and
drain this three over the top screwed
her now is trying to garden hardness
pounded goes the forecourt possibility
which leads to compel on the step back
three intruder was all over Hart
he bumped him down low after the shot
you'll see right here fouls to give both
in the penalty under two to play hard
step back
what's up the three got head chance goes
James Harden double-team got a chance
for a four-point play one up and two boy
Adam left coach you like that content I
know you like that content hit subscribe
for more of it from Bleacher Report